last Saturday Akash saying headlines the
infamous Wilbert theater in Boston
to the homie tell us about the show what
was it like that was one of the best
nights of my life maybe the best night
of my career wow the Wilbur man you know
this Andrew Mark you you told me this
it's like an amazing venue but there's
probably like four bucket list theaters
for me there's Radio City yeah uh
there's like the Majestic because my
first comedy show is seeing Chappelle
there like right before he blew up crazy
where's the Majestic it's in Dallas okay
it's in the Anne's home uh Chicago
Theater just because you always see in
Chicago and then the Wilbur was the one
that like every comic talks about
theaters yeah and then they talk about
the Wilbur yeah it's like the best venue
it's the best theater for stand-up yeah
it's awesome in my opinion everybody
says that and I was on my dreams like
I'd see so and so at the Wilbur this guy
Andrews at the Wilbur and I was like yo
I gotta do the Wilbur and this is my
first time headline in Boston ever so we
skipped the clubs did the Wilbur it sold
out before I got there so I didn't have
that [__] stress of like moving extra
tickets and so I could just focus on
hammering down the intro getting a dole
player who's competent which you managed
to do they showed up um yeah the intro
was fired the intro I came wait to show
you all the video I'm having Kev send
one I used to hear people doing the
Wilbur and yeah dude I cannot wait to
[__] do the wheel for you let me sold
this one out it was cool very cool
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
but then I felt like once I got out
there I went to the theater the day
before to look and like see this is what
I'm looking at don't get this is the
biggest venue you've done take it in
headline at least don't get overwhelmed
I went to the top look down to
appreciate it all and then when I went
out there I felt like I had fun because
the Wilbur allows you to treat it like a
comedy club and do crowd work yeah and
then I felt like I hit my marks the
audience was [__] amazing Boston is
such a good comedy City all the best
they're smart they're willing to laugh
they're willing to go they're willing to
get flagrant and we just had so much
[__] fun doing good it was so like
everything I thought it would be amazing
what was anxiety before and then Ray
when you got on stage what happened the
anxiety honestly there's anxiety in that
like
I know the bar you set for your shows
and I'm like yo if you're coming to see
me they probably found out about me
through you it needs to match we're
making a [__] show this is not I'm
gonna come do my jokes and then we're
gonna leave I want to have ill jokes and
Ill punch lines and everything but I
want to make sure I hit all the marks
before that and make sure everybody
leaves feeling like yo that was an
experience that was an experience so
that was new to me I'd never done that
and so I'm still trying to learn that
and the fact that we were able to pull
all that off shouts to the the punga
team that came here to dance here they
came fudge they were amazing we had a DJ
Ryan records was amazing doll player
ummer was a great and it just once we
hit that then it was just remember you
sold these tickets and you can do this
and don't get overwhelmed yeah and then
I felt like I was able to do that and
have fun which is also like when you get
especially me when I get tight I'm
having less fun and then everything is
like me yeah so if I and I remember to
have fun and like [__] around with a
crowd and just live in the moment and it
was it was the world through a lens of
discomfort yeah and picking up on more
discomfort when you're having fun you're
just noticing all the other people
having fun and that's giving me more
energy to expand on it and if if you're
doing like flagrant material yeah if
you're not having fun it just feels
weird it's like you know when I just got
angry about it yeah it comes across like
you're not even joking about it yeah so
for me especially you know comments
something I think you've got a lot
better at yeah in your careers like it's
like executing jokes that can be
um I don't want to say it's not
distasteful but they can come across as
angry yeah and finding a way to do it by
being silly and like having fun yes yeah
in a way and it's more honest because I
don't I'm not actually angry about these
things sometimes anger is like an easier
emotion to tap into yeah you know like
if you tell people like be a certain way
like have an emotion it's it's it's it's
harder for people to go I'm perplexed
yeah than it is to be like I'm angry
yeah you know yeah so yeah it's like
maybe the first thing that we move
ourselves to or maybe that's the reason
why we're writing jokes as we were angry
in the moment but not angry in a way
like you actually hate this person it's
more like frustration yeah yeah and in
life I just I'm gonna get really
emotional about something and then it's
done and I didn't realize every I
thought everybody work like that like
y'all see me before pot sometimes I got
an issue I'm [__] I'm going off but
then I'm done I get it out yeah
sometimes I gotta make sure to remember
people don't know I'm not being fully
serious so especially with bits that are
flagrant or if I'm [__] with an
audience member pretending like I'm kind
of playfully upset I gotta make sure
that that's something I've had to work
on a lot is making sure it comes across
at least in the room like oh he's not
actually angry angry he's just [__]
around yeah guys that clip you just
watched was a part of our patreon now if
you want to watch the full patreon
episode if you want to join the other 20
000 [__] Army members go to
patreon.com flagrant